excuse me excuse me could I have
detention just want to say good evening
my name is richard ryan and i'm the
senior Washington correspondent for the
Detroit News and president of the
National Press Club I'm honored to
welcome such a distinguished audience to
the Press Club this evening it is a
tribute to Marvin calve
the man and the journalist that so many
people are here tonight to hear him talk
about his latest book
Marvin as I'm sure you all know is a
journalistic icon he is what many of us
in this business aspire to be both
successful and respected during the
distinguished 30-year career as chief
diplomatic correspondent for CBS News
and NBC News and his moderator of Meet
the Press Marvin has won many awards for
reporting
they include 2p to Peabody prizes from
the University of Georgia the DuPont
prize from Columbia University and more
than a half-dozen overseas Press Club
Awards
Marvin is currently the executive
director of the Washington office of the
Jones Shorenstein Center on press
politics and public policy for the
previous twelve years he directed the
Center at Harvard University's John F
Kennedy School of Government and where
he also taught and lectured next Tuesday
right here at the National Press Club
Marvin will interview a CBS News anchor
Dan Rather about the recent terrorist
attacks in New York and Washington the
discussion is the first in a seven part
series entitled the Kalba reports but
Marvin is here tonight to discuss his
tenth and latest book it's entitled one
scandalous story Clinton Lewinsky and
thirteen days that tarnished American
journalism Donna shillelagh President
Clinton's former Secretary of Health and
Human Services said this about Marvin's
book only a world-class journalist could
dissect his own professions reporting of
the messy scandal that ruined a
presidency this is a brilliant
unsettling book
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Marvin kelp
thank you very much to have to say that
your leadership of the National Press
Club has been truly inspiring
I mean I have a sense of a beat in this
place since you've taken over so I
salute you for the work that you've done
my thanks also to Jerry's REM ski who
was chair of the Professional Affairs
Committee which is sponsoring tonight's
event and Jerry is not here because you
know reporters he has to cover a story
and my thanks to John bloom whose
general manager the National Press Club
John took a shaky financial institution
and he has turned it into a winner and
what can I possibly say about Julie shoe
Membership Director of the club she is
fantastic a very special person who was
helped me in a thousand ways I start
with a question is there a relationship
between the reporting of a war against
terrorism which is where we are right
now and the political war that ransacked
Washington three years ago in 1998 when
President Clinton was caught where he
shouldn't have been my answer to the
question much to my pleasant surprise
has proven to be yes just the other day
I was at a meeting of Washington bureau
chiefs here at the Press Club the topic
was coverage of the current scandal of
crisis
time and again these excellent
journalists referred to the Clinton
Lewinsky scandal as the time they
learned certain lessons about
contemporary journalism as practiced
here in Washington and they're now
trying to apply to the coverage of
terrorism and I have to tell you that
maybe feel awfully good I spent a long
time researching and writing this book
for that basic reason what could we
learn from one experience that could
possibly be applied to another one
scandalous story
it was certainly that a President of the
United States converted the Oval Office
into an occasional frat house he lied
under oath before a grand jury which led
to his impeachment shamefully he lied
before the entire nation angrily
pointing his finger I did not have
sexual relations with that woman miss
Lewinsky he disgraced the highest office
in the land who could even be argue that
the Clinton Lewinsky scandal left an
unmistakable stench over the 2000
campaign which george w bush neatly
exploited at every Whistlestop bush
you'll remember promised to return
dignity to the Oval Office what could he
possibly have had in mind because the
story wreaked of illicit sex between a
president and an intern and because it
raised important legal and political
questions it sparked a prairie fire of
copycat journalism that quickly spawned
the publication of many books all of
them approaching the subject from a
different vantage point depending on the
author's background reporter Michael
Isikoff led the parade then Monica
Lewinsky herself then reported Jeffrey
Toobin lawyer Lanny Davis Post editor
Bob Woodward Matt Drudge speaking of
Matt Drudge he wrote The Drudge
manifesto which actually made its way
onto the new you
Times bestseller list which is a mystery
I'm still trying to fathom reporter
Susan Schmidt Michael Wiese cuff
reporters scholars bill Kovich and Tom
rosensteil all of them did very fine
work but for the real insider poop on
this scandal I'm afraid we're all going
to have to wait until 2003 when this
drew mrs. Clinton will unveil in
separate memoirs their precious secrets
offer it at astronomical rates of their
time in the White House and their
remarkable marriage they both pleaded
for a zone of privacy
you'll recall that but then so the right
to their privacy to the highest bidder
mr. ex-president signed for a reported
twelve million dollar advance
breaking every record in publishing
history leaving even the Pope in his
wake and this is junior senator from New
York got a more modest eight million
dollar advance and why surely not
because they are both pew litter Prize
winning writers and surely not because
of their wonkish excursions into health
care reform they got their estimated
twenty million dollars in book advances
on a reckless publishers hunch that now
they were finally ready to tell the
truth about their private lives their
loves and there are political lusts sure
in all these books and there are many
more we've been able to learn much about
the role of the Independent Counsel the
president's been dr. The Washington
lawyers the dark conspirators the
emotional intern the matrons betrayal
the impeachment process however until
now the day-to-day doings of the
reporter editor and anchor have not been
subjected to serious sustained analysis
which the journalists powerful position
in Washington truly warranted in this
scandalous story
the journalist deserved his or her time
in the Sun the reason is that the
journalist played an indispensable role
in carrying the story from one side of
the Washington battlefield to the other
the other being the office of the
Independent Counsel the White House was
there on one side the OIC on the other
Clinton fighting stars star Clinton both
manipulating the press to their own
maximum advantage the journalist in such
a war was not without judgment and yet
in this war the journalists often acted
as if judgment mattered not at all
driven by an old-fashioned competition
and a new fashioned technology sensing a
pulitzer prize in the hazy near distance
the journalist helped old standards to
fall and new ones to be created and the
public was left either enchanted by a
sexual scandal or baffled but what was
really happening certainly confused with
OJ Simpson's trial and Princess Diana's
travails this presidential scandal
helped define the news of the 90s and
opened a new Vista on in on the
information revolution sweeping one
century into another New York Times
columnist Frank Rich labeled these 24/7
TV mini-series as media thongs or total
national emotions played out in real
time before a mass audience
the scandal became an all-consuming
inescapable national obsession
obliterating other news of importance
and reshaping while lowering
journalistic standards the story marks
an important chapter in the history of
American journalism in and of itself
this was enough of a reason for writing
this book but there was actually another
reason as I approach the end of my
12-year stint as founding director of
the show
Stane Center I wanted to do something at
a university that generally means
writing a book do something that would
help my students understand the intimate
complex relationship of the press now
widely referred to as the media to the
business of politics and to the
fashioning of public policy more
concretely I had to answer a number of
their basic questions born of skepticism
even cynicism about contemporary press
and politics do public officials have a
right to a zone of privacy do reporters
rush to judgment without adequate
reliable information does the new
technology including the Internet
affect the production and quality of
news does the merging of the media into
ever bigger more powerful conglomerates
affect the politics of nations and the
values of journalism think for example
of AOL Time Warner the marriage of the
Internet to both news and entertainment
any number of ideas for a book answered
answering these questions or least
attempting to answer these questions
have been running through my mind
literally for years a book that would be
practical and valuable in a classroom
and yet appealing to a wider audience
but none of these ideas seemed quite
right none that is until January 21st
1998 when the Washington Post reported
that President Clinton had been caught
in an affair with a White House intern
and that he had urged her to lie about
it
within hours television pundits were on
the air speculating about impeachment
within days journalism was engaged in a
media thon of unparalleled proportion
I had my subject one composed of power
innocence politics and sex
through a sharply focused lens an
academic jargon a case study I decided I
would try to explain the story of
Washington journalism 13 days in a
scandal that was to preoccupy the nation
for the next 13 months eight days
leading up to the breaking of the story
the day it broke and four days
thereafter splattered across every paper
every news program every talk show as if
nothing else in the world mattered from
the very beginning a question always
seemed to hang over the entire project
demanding an answer Kennedy was as
guilty of sexual transgressions
transgressions as Clinton perhaps even
more so yet the press chose never to lay
a glove on Kennedy and as we know all
too sadly the press pummeled Clinton how
come time and again I was confronted
with the same question the answer turned
out to be both simple and complicated
simple in that the press changed
profoundly complicated in why it changed
my both simple and complicated answer
started with another scandalous story
dating back to September 20th 1963
President Kennedy was in New York to
address the 18th General Assembly at the
UN he stayed at the Carlyle Hotel after
his speech he attended a formal dinner
later in the evening Kennedy had an
unscheduled visitor a blonde with
stunningly attractive legs
I know because I saw her being escorted
into his private elevator by two Secret
Service agents flanked by two other
Secret Service agents one of them
panicked by the unexpected presence of a
reporter knocked me to the ground a few
minutes later the blonde safely
delivered to her destination the agent
returned and apologized he was flustered
embarassed good god I said what happened
why did you push me who was that woman
he looked up at the ceiling as if
appealing to higher perhaps presidential
authority and shook his head he
apologized again and left I went to my
room wondering whether I should file a
formal complaint with pierre salinger
the president's spokesman after all
Secret Service agents are not supposed
to push or bully a journalist but I did
nothing as I talked about this incident
now some 38 years later I am amazed not
by my decision to do nothing but by the
fact quite undeniable that never for one
instant that I even consider pursuing
and reporting what I had seen and
experienced that night it was my
judgment at the time that the whole
incident was simply not news although
there has never been one commonly
accepted definition of news it has
usually been defined broadly as what's
new what's relevant what's interesting
what's timely and what sells in those
days the possibility of a presidential
affair while titillating was not
considered news by the mainstream press
though tabloids existed those were not
tabloid times not when the Cuban Missile
Crisis was still a fresh memory of the
nuclear dangers of the Cold War not when
racial tensions were again clawing at
the soul of the nation rumors persisted
about what Ben Bradley called Kennedy's
extracurricular screwing but the rumors
never rose to the level of a news story
not at CBS News where I worked and not
at the New York Times were another young
reporter RW Apple jr. worked as Apple
later described his scandalous story he
also was at the Carlyle when he saw and
I
a beautiful woman being escorted to
Kennedy suite it was again 1963 UN time
in New York Apple saw visions of a
front-page story dancing before his eyes
he returned to The Times office on West
43rd Street and excitedly told his story
to sheldon bin the chief assignment
editor bin listened impatiently Apple he
said when Apple had finished you're
supposed to report on political and
diplomatic policies not on girlfriends
no story let us say for a moment however
that I had decided that it was a story
what would I have broadcast did I know
for an absolute fact that the woman was
being escorted to the president's suite
no did I see her face no her name no I
learned it later but I didn't know what
that was there possibly an innocent
explanation could she have been just a
friend a relative unlikely friends and
relatives are not secretly hustled into
rear elevators late at night by Secret
Service agents anything was possible but
at the time given what I had seen and
heard I knew in my gut that the
president was having an illicit affair
and the Secret Service was complicit in
arranging it and hushing it up let us
take my scenario one step further I
wrote the story and submitted it to my
CBS editors who in turn passed it on to
Walter Cronkite for final approval they
all would have thought I had gone mad
meaning the story was not written and it
would not have been approved for
broadcast because it did not satisfy the
accepted journalistic norms of the day
between then and now these norms have
dramatically changed now I suspect my
story would quickly come to Domino
the Internet provide fodder for radio
and television talk shows work its way
into the mainstream media and then
assault the front page for the evening
news on the strength of an ensuing run
of allegations denials White House
cover-ups congressional and journalistic
investigations during the research in
the writing of this book what did I as a
journalist learn about journalism more
than anything else I learned that
journalists to quote the late John
Osborne have glass jaws all of their
professional lives they have been
lashing out at politicians criticizing
them for every sin large and small
personal and professional when the
pummeled politician screamed unfair
untrue give me a break
the journalists only seem to rise to the
bait regarding each complaint as proof
that they are right and the politicians
are either being evasive or guilty as
charged we throw punches all day long
Tom Brokaw said but as soon as someone
winds up and looks as if they may throw
a punch at us we go down whining and
screaming in great pain Glassdoor
journalism it might be called I know I
know I have already heard from many of
the outrage reporters whose work has
been described in this book reporters
who pounded a president on a daily basis
who dismantled a young woman whose only
crime was that she fell foolishly for
the most prominent politician in the
land reporters who criticize Congress
nothing wrong with that but who then
coddled the office of the Independent
Counsel who abandoned their role as
objective observers to become subjective
participants these same reporters
feeling the sting of a butterfly that's
me
called and complained on an hourly basis
sometimes ferociously of unfair
criticism on my part shall I name these
reporters no they're all in the book but
when and if criticized fairly or
unfairly to quote Brokaw they go down
whining screaming an anguished
indignation that they have been
misrepresented misquoted and mistreated
Harry Truman once said if you can't
stand the heat stay out of the kitchen
but these days journalists benefit from
the excitement and notoriety of the
kitchen
but they don't like the heat I learned
other lessons about journalism too first
the lesson of what might be called out
there in January 1992 when Jennifer
flowers story first broke in a
supermarket tabloid producers and
anchors at NPR's all things considered
wondered whether they should use the
story although a number of produces
favored using the story executive
producer Ellen Weiss and anchor Linda
Wertheimer had their doubts Weiss
observed The Times only ran a hundred
words inside somewhere why should we
just because some paper in Florida did
the producers stressed that the story
was after all out there it could not be
ignored Weiss said that doesn't mean it
has to be in here a line from another
era of journalism when a different ethic
ruled the waves between flowers in 1992
and Lewinsky in 1998 the distinction
between out there and in here vanished
in the crush of journalistic competition
in the loss of a journalistic ethic that
placed public policy ahead of corporate
greed reporters felt they
had no option once the scandal was
reported almost every news organization
had to get into the act whether they had
authoritative confirmation or not for
example it was widely reported on
January 25th 1998 that a White House
steward had actually seen Clinton and
Lewinsky in a compromising position was
their confrontation no were there
denials yes did the denials discourage
most reporters from doing the story time
and time and time again no only two
reporters I know John Broder and Steven
Levitan of the New York Times refused to
succumb to the competitive pressures
they had heard the same rumors for a
time they thought they had independent
confirmation the times readied a banner
headline one that could have toppled the
Clinton presidency but at the last
moment Broder and Labbit and realized
that their sourcing was highly suspect
and they refused to write the story
which so far as The Times was concerned
was out there but it was not to be in
here on that day The Times was the
exception another lesson best summarized
as why wait for evidence when you can
always rush to judgment by January 1998
unless a president could prove he was
telling the truth
reporters assumed he was lying
dissembling cutting corners for the
purpose of elevating his political
profile or saving his political backside
from the moment they heard about the
possibility of a sexual relationship
reporters operated on a presumption of
presidential guilt they thought it felt
right they didn't need facts to confirm
their instincts indeed on occasion facts
seemed to get in their way there were
few constraints left in a journalist
pursuit
good story everything everyone was
considered fair gang from the trivial to
the towering from underwear boxer shorts
you'll remember to impeachment still
another lesson what David Broder many
years ago referred to as blurring the
lines for a long time
reporters were the observers they were
not the observed now many of them have
become observers and observed from their
phone booths in recent years they have
emerged not as supermen quite but as
instantly recognizable celebrities they
all work and live in a world of
television which more than any other
tool of modern communication facilitates
the blurring of the line between press
and politics a government official
leaves his or her White House or
congressional or government job and
becomes a commentator or columnist so
what you may ask one answer is that the
public after a while has difficulty
distinguishing who's who in the
Washington power elite who's the
reporter who's the official who's
telling the truth who shaving the truth
indeed in these slippery times what is
the truth in a democracy the truth
teller holds the keys to the kingdom the
journalists used to be the truth teller
but now Russ Wiggins of the post was one
of the first to spot the problem
journalists belong in the audience he'd
often tell his reporters not on the
stage Ben Bradlee pinpointed the crucial
role of Watergate coverage he wrote
Watergate marked the final passage of
journalists into the best seats in the
establishment sadly once in the best
seats journalists were then expected to
produce more than just good clean copy
they were also expected to deliver their
opinions and their opinions carried
weight it
universe shared with other celebrities
spouting equally controversial
criss-crossing insights right or wrong
the once glorious if somewhat mundane
pursuit of the truth now seems simply to
humble a calling the temptation to
perform to pontificate to rise above the
story clearly became irresistible as the
editorial walls separating straight
reporting from commentary political
participants from political observers
crumbled in a heap journalism took a
large step towards becoming a business
just like any other business except it
is the only business in America
protected by the First Amendment to the
US Constitution turn on your set there
are now so many X politico's of one sort
or another acting as reporters or
pundits that authentic journalists who
once covered City Hall or the Vietnam
War seems suddenly to have become an
extinct species Mike McCurry Tony
Blankley David Gergen George
Stephanopoulos Paul Begala Peggy Noonan
and Oliver North Lanny Davis Newt
Gingrich Tony Snow bill press and many
others some by the way quite good at
what they do and so on
no more damaging example exists in the
back and forth government journalism
confusion then the role John Ellis
played on election night 2000 as head of
the New York election and decision does
of the Fox News Channel he spent 11
years at NBC where I knew him and then
wrote a superb column for the Boston
Globe
before quitting in the summer of 1999
because as he explained in his
concluding column his cousin George W
Bush was running for president they were
very close and he didn't think he could
any longer be objective on election
night
Ellis spoke with his cousin six
times six times to George and once to
his cousin jeigh quote both gave us he
later wrote very valuable information
these conversations help me better
understand the data that were appearing
on our screen at 2:16 a.m. Wednesday
morning Fox leather parade the first
network to project Bush the winter in
Florida and the nation way back in 1988
Broder wrote we damn well better make it
clear we are not part of the government
and not part of a Washington insiders
clique where politicians publicists and
journalists are easily interchangeable
parts once we lose our distinctive
identity we will no longer we will not
be long it will not be long before we
lose our freedom once we lose our
distinctive identity it will not be long
before we lose our freedom journalists
in my opinion are losing their
distinctive identity they're
irreplaceable place in our society now
anyone can be a journalist or at least
play one on television finally in my
list of lessons is this matter of
sources or as I put it in the book the
lack thereof no issue of press
performance disturbed and disappointed
me more than the hurried abandonment of
some of the basic rules of using and
identifying sources as I wrote in the
book a direct quote here sources come in
many shapes and sizes sources who know
the full story and share it honestly
with a reporter sources who know the
whole story but share only part of it
and thereby convey an incomplete picture
sources who know only part of the story
but suggest they know all of it
sources who know only part of the story
and candidly
convey only that part leaving to the
report of the responsibility of getting
the rest of the story from other people
sources who know none of the basic
details of the story but for political
or psychological reasons cannot
acknowledge the truth and end up telling
the reporter only what they have read in
the papers that morning or heard on talk
radio when the drive into work or
spotted on a website of dubious
reliability sources who consciously spin
a story for political or selfish
advantage in this city there are many of
those sources who enjoy the game of
politics and will say anything to a
reporter in order to get mentioned in
the paper or get invited onto a
talk-show sources who hide behind the
loosest language for the time-honored
purpose of leaking a politically charged
story unquote which of these sources in
the early days of the scandal knew
anything and who talked there were five
groups first and most important the
troika of Lewinsky trippin Goldberg
Lewinsky was the basic source of
information she talked to Tripp and
Tripp then talked to Goldberg and others
the fluence key was wrong
a succession of wrongs then ensued
second the office of the Independent
Counsel the OIC led by Kenneth Starr
strongly supported by his deputy Jacquie
Bennett they talked and leaked to a very
limited number of reporters third the
White House and the Department of
Justice unwittingly in many cases
officials there lied because the
president had lied to them the
Department of Justice was much more
truthful fourth the band of lawyers
representing all of the players they
talked to one another and a few of them
very few of them
then talk to reporters finally the
Internet
starting with Matt Drudge then very
quickly moving on to Newsweek and
finally into every newsroom in the
country but in those early days when the
shape of the story was formed very few
reporters a mere handful had any
reliable information most of the others
simply had what was out there what had
already been published in The Washington
Post or Newsweek what had been broadcast
by ABC would have been discussed on talk
radio and television and the handful
that had reliable information felt the
need to protect their sources if they
got an antique Clinton tidbit from the
OIC they told their readers and viewers
that they got it from sources if they
got a self-serving pro-clinton tidbit
from a White House lawyer they also said
that they got it from sources no one
reading or watching had any idea who
these sources were reliable biased
questionable who knew the reporters knew
the sources knew the public didn't know
at the end of the book I quoted to
journalists dan Rather of CBS and Sondra
Mims Roe of The Oregonian rather in 1993
told radio and TV news directors quote
we've all gone Hollywood we've also come
to the Hollywood ization of the news
just to cover our ears we give the best
slots to gossip the post more generation
of owners and managers aren't venal
they're afraid they've got education and
taste and good sense they care about
their country but you'd never know it
from the things here this that fear
makes them do from the things that fear
makes them make us do unquote row in
1998 told newspaper editors quote other
media that do not share newspaper
standards are recasting the definition
of news but we do not have to be pulled
along new media will not adopt our
standards the high road is there if we
will just take it the notion that
readers have created the demand for
lowest-common-denominator journalism she
wrote and said is false we are doing
that ourselves we can and must stop
unquote so far with one major exception
that of what happened on September 11th
and what followed as a result of the
events of September 11th news
organizations have not stopped their
reckless pursuit of profit over public
interest I want to believe that
journalism can change for the better and
must change for the better the evidence
at the moment while depressing is only
the accumulated results of many
individual decisions by Network
presidents anchors reporters editors
producers writers commentators if they
were to change their ways the evidence
would also change dan Rather was right
it would take just a few good wet good
men and women of courage to start
very much
if anyone would like to ask a question
this is that time right here due to a
chance to talk to Dan Rather about why
he left coupon like all the other
reporters remember that that first
couple days they always away the
question of relates to Wednesday the day
that the story broke January 21st 1998
the anchors were all in Cuba because the
Pope was about to arrive on a very
important mission all of the anchors
left Koppel left first and the other
three left immediately thereafter and
they all left because yes I did talk to
them they all left because they felt
that the biggest story they know at that
time was happening in Washington and
they had to get to where the biggest
story was and so they left the Pope and
joined the Monaco trail yes Dan being is
extinct reporter you go back to that go
back to the story about the blonde at
the Carlyle Hotel yeah I want to I'm
right on that other because it wasn't
clear what your position was I don't
want to know the name of her by the way
of you if you know it I'll be happy to
know but anyway you can put in a sealed
envelope and pass it around
oh but in a in a sense in a sense don't
you I mean I would feel that the
everybody was to be with Johnny happen
the editor that times was right not to
to follow the story and people at CBS
were right now you didn't know very much
about it
they could have say they're painted
oysters in the room right they prepare a
prayer meeting up there you don't know
we're gonna do it and that I mean to go
prayer meeting the Secret Service
how do you know what's the difference I
mean he said they're protecting her
religion but the point is you know the
fact of the matter is you didn't know
what I mean if you had some hard news
that would be one thing but just to see
a dame going i elevate her upstairs is
not enough to make a story right now
less like misunderstood I think your
point is today that would be a story but
in your day it was rightly not a story
what I was saying I hope was that at
that time it was not only not a story it
never occurred to me for one instance
that it was however today it would be a
story and it would go through that odd
series of twists and turns of
contemporary journalism where something
has heard on the radio and then it maybe
picked up on the internet and then Tom
Brokaw described us very well and he
called it the Big Bang Theory of
journalism today that something could
start with a very small bang in the
morning but become the lead of the
nightly news that night simply because
it goes through all of the channels that
today compose the media and at the end
of the day what starts out as a rumor
may end up as what appears to be a hard
fact and since the standards today are
not that rigid between rumor in fact by
the end of the day when it appears this
fact everybody's happy they got a big
story there's one observation Johnson by
the way and Kathy Martin's book which is
coming out will have a lot of evidence
on Johnson also and
right yeah sure she interviewed Lady
Bird who tells us tells everybody about
how she tolerated Johnson's philandering
getting to get into the truck trucks the
years during which have read the book it
I don't think there's anything we should
be going after these guys for what the
hell they're doing
in the Clinton case it's not the sex
that matters is the line that matters
right I think that the the lying
certainly mattered and without any doubt
impeaching a president matters but it
all started in an odd kind of way and
one of the things that I try to point
out to the end of of the book is since
Lewinsky was at one point in the story
the sole source president wasn't talking
she was the sole source
she also said to many of her friends
that she'd like to lie she liked to make
things up she liked to fantasize
it was one of the things that made one
of her friends on one of the first
Nightline programs after the story broke
say to Ted that I like Monica very much
but when we went to school she always
rather proudly told us that she
fantasized that leaked half of what you
then told us as if it were true now
supposing when you have a single source
Monica who brings the information to
Linda Tripp who gives the information to
the OIC which is waiting for a whole
range of other reasons to go after the
president and you provide that little
bit of information that this man was
engaged in a sexual affair with a 22
year old White House intern every one of
those lawyers licked his chops and said
go for it and they did and then the
leaking began to certain reporters the
one who started it all was Michael
Isikoff of
week.this akov had a direct line into
Linda Tripp and she gave him the whole
story based on one source Monica now
supposing when Monica said to Linda
Tripp that she was having an affair with
the president she was engaging in
another one of her fantasies a lot would
have flowed from a fantasy at a certain
point we all might have known what the
truth was but not at this point in these
13 days in in that period of time
everybody was going on the word of one
person and that to me is is tricky and
dangerous particularly for journalists
point what would be the second or third
paragraph back in 1963 of the story had
it been accepted by CBS News from you or
by Sheldon been at the New York Times or
Johnny Apple once you'd said or
established in some fashion that
something other than Stan Lee's I
thought picturesque notion of a prayer
meeting had occurred there what would
you say about let's say you establish
the facts okay what would you say um
fortunate fortunately I didn't write the
story no idea
but I can imagine I can imagine that a
number of things could have flown I
could have reported the little bit that
I saw with I could have reported that
you asked me what how would I do it that
would have been one element in the story
another hang on another element would
have been a pursuit on my part at that
time with the help of other CBS
reporters including two first class
White House reporters about everything
that they had heard felt they knew at
the time about Kennedy's philandering in
other words we would have gone from the
one incident
that one reporter saw to the information
that was available that was known by a
number of other white house
correspondents who were closed up on and
then as you well know you would be going
to other people as well you would be
presenting a portrait of a president
quite different from the one that the
public had at that time you might not
have had nailed down every detail likely
you wouldn't you couldn't but the image
that the American people would have had
of their president would have been
dramatically 100 percent different from
the image that they had at that time at
that time any number of people could
have engaged in rumors and did but they
wouldn't have been on CBS or printed in
the New York Times brilliant
what I'd like you to speculate about it
pardon me given the portrait of the
media's you just offered it to us what
are we to be on guard against with
respect to the media to covering the
terrorist story well that is one of the
things that the as I said at the very
beginning that the Washington bureau
chiefs were making their comparison
between the coverage of the Lewinsky
scandal and the coverage of the crisis
now and what they said so I'm just
reporting now what they said was one
that when a reporter comes in now very
prominent bureau chief and the reporter
says to the bureau chief I just heard
about this phenomenal thing that is
going on we are already sending special
units into Afghanistan and the bureau
chief says do we know that for a fact
and the reporter says well I don't
really have it confirmed but I heard
that and I know for a fact that the
Washington Post is going to go with it
so I think that we at the Times might
consider going with it and what they
feel now is that just because something
is out there that does not mean that
they have to do with themselves and they
were very mindful of that lesson from
the 98 experience they were also very
mindful and all of them in effect picked
us up that let us please try to stick
with the facts that we have and not
express our opinions ease off on the
opinions keep after the op-ed page in
that editorial page but not for the news
stories that this is too important to be
playing around in the edges of gray
matter and let's stick to the black and
white that is those are the two main
points that they made based on the
lessons of of 98
Ernie Shaw
it only takes a few good men and women
to resurrect crumbling journalistic
standards evaluate the press the media
what do you see are you hopeful I guess
the answer to that bernie is that I'm
not but let me explain why the the
evidence that I have all of the research
that I did for this book and a lot of
other stuff leads me to believe that
there are two large forces at work now
in journalism very large a one is
economics and the other is the new
technology and the economics and the new
technology combined to produce larger
and larger corporations you started
working 20 years ago at CNN when it was
regarded with ridicule as the chicken
noodle Network when you left who was one
of the most respected organizations in
the world at this particular time CNN is
not what it was then or even 10 years
ago it is now a small pimple on the
backside of a AOL Time Warner it is a
small part of a gigantic corporation and
when the person representing CNN goes to
the corporate board and tries to argue
for more money for example he's not
going to be listened to as seriously as
he was before it is a different mindset
that has taken over since about the mid
80s I worry for example may Bernie less
about the coverage today of the crisis
one of the big issues right now is that
before the crisis erupted on September
11th the media was already on a
downslide in terms of economic strength
as you well know they are they lost in
the first week and s
1 billion dollars since that time they
continued to hemorrhage and losing money
at what point at what point is somebody
in control of the money can it turn to
somebody in control of the editorial
content and say time kid we may be doing
too much of us my judgment would be that
so long as the patriotism runs as high
as emotional as it is today the person
controlling the money is going to be
hard pressed to say I'm going to ease
off on the flow so in other words by
bottom line that is that the moment the
evidence suggests to me more of the same
and no opportunity in the near future
for it to hit bottom and begin to take
off go up if you spoke of the media's
First Amendment protections yes under
the Constitution yes my concern is for
the American consumer reader listener
viewer of news what Z course does he or
her hat well thank God there are many
many many different newspapers magazines
radio television and all of that and I
would rest my hopes with the energy with
which a good citizen will address the
problem of self-education there is there
are many ways of learning things about
what's going on now I don't think that's
the problem at all the problem is that
with individual news organizations they
tend to get lost in the pursuit of
profit rather than a more antique
version of pursuing the benefits of
public policy tick Solomon is right
there admiring your description of
the dilemma of according to what Monica
had said the Linda trip was I think
assailable in the following way
responding to that was in the broader
context of Jennifer flowers and Paul of
Paula Jones etc etc and so people were
coming at the rumors not from a blank
slate perspective with a lot of other
information that suggested aha pattern
is being reaffirmed which is not to say
that your point that hey you needed more
confirmation that this just wasn't of
the young girls fantasy is is is not
true I think it is but what impresses me
is frankly how journalism generally
zeroes in on the on the character issues
very very effectively I mean as you
heard for years the big eye of
television really does expose the
qualities of a personality and people
pick up on anything
journalism plays in that in that context
it's not to justify but just to say that
I mean I just got a copy of the book but
what's the title of it would be
interesting for you to document cases
where the journalist community
got home and this is we're sitting here
the one case where has popped into my
head is the poor guy down at the world
that the Olympics was singled out
because the FBI needed a scapegoat and
he was Richard Jewell and and that that
poor guy got savage now to build up a
dossier or a record of many cases or the
few cases where the journalist community
got it wrong which lengthen your your
case tonight yeah and and what I have in
the next to last chapter are two
interesting examples of where the Dallas
Morning News in the Wall Street Journal
simply got it wrong and then apologized
a couple of days later because there are
two very reputable organizations and
didn't like the idea that they got it
wrong they were embarrassed they
apologized I take my hat off to that I
think it's terrific and it is not a joy
for me to write negative things about
journalism I love journalism and I love
journalists I spent most of my life
being a journalist I think what we do is
crucially important to the vibrancy of a
democracy and that's why I feel even
more strongly that when they get it
wrong or at least do not perform up to a
first-rate level they're doing something
that undercuts not only their
credibility but the vitality of the
country itself the two are intimately
connected so what is it is with no
pleasure that I point out something
negative about the American press it is
still the best press in the world Daniel
Schorr you will be sore for yesterday
that's all right there's nothing a first
time
Marvin you referred a couple of times to
a meeting of bureau chiefs discussing
the coverage of the events starting with
and after September the 11th this was
sponsored by the John Shorenstein Center
and was held right here and I was
invited to it and told that the meeting
would be off the record and whereupon I
declined to go can you explain why when
journalists discussed doing journalism
they would want to be off the record
that was a decision made by the the
director of the Shorenstein Center and I
support all decisions of the director of
the shorts Lisa Dan as you well know for
the first 12 years of its existence the
Shorenstein Center never had an
off-the-record session everything was on
the record but I can fully understand
what Alex Jones had in mind what he was
trying to do was to stimulate a
discussion among reporters about things
that are being done well things that are
being done questionably things that may
evenly done wrong and in the privacy of
an off-the-record discussion perhaps
they would all feel more comfortable
easier to concede problems one thing or
another and and I must say that it was a
terrific discussion it was extremely
interesting to you a reporter Deborah
Mathis is in the back she would like to
ask a question never looking for a like
your response to the question about
about instances where journalists got it
wrong weren't you really sir aren't you
really saying in your book it isn't as
part of your standard responsiveness in
your belief that it's not necessarily
that they got it wrong in this case or
in other cases but if they put it out
there before they knew they had it right
and that is the reason before they knew
they had wrong yeah yeah and I think
that's that's really the issue from what
I know of you that you're saying that
but my question is about what's going on
right now
and although this this are of patriotism
is it's smothering all of us including
the press and maybe rightfully so but I
worry about the coverage of this war
because the information is being dished
out to us only from after it's been
completely cleared supposedly we have
very few ways of verifying it with our
own two eyes and ears and we don't know
whether we're being used as in part of
the strategy or not if we are passing on
truth or passing on illusion and but we
run the risk at this point of being
attacked as being unpatriotic if we even
question some of these things I listen
to Ari Fleischer today in his briefing
who would not answer some of the most
cursory questions on the pretense that
it had to deal with national security
and it was operational detail how does
this new crop of journalists deal with
that kind of situation and get fact out
to the public it's going to be very
difficult it's going to be very very
difficult and the you've already
mentioned the key ingredients there is
an an enveloping totally understandable
widely shared feeling of patriotism this
country was brutally attacked and there
is a strong sense that you want to fight
back and do something
we vest all of our confidence and hopes
in our government that the government is
going to have to come up with the right
answers to a lot of very complicated
problems and this is a war like no other
that the US has ever fought and the
president is going to have to make some
very difficult calls he already made one
very difficult call among many others
but one on that first day when the plane
that that was going West circled around
and came back over Pittsburgh and then
crashed there was an assumption that
that plane was coming back to hit some
building in Washington DC and the
president's order according to the vice
president was to shoot that plane down
even though it had innocent Americans on
board that's a gigantic decision but I
have a feeling it is simply one of many
decisions of that nature they're gonna
have to be made so when when the
government when the administration asks
as it has any number of times now for
press cooperation and understand it and
if the press has something that is
secret and obviously very sensitive hold
it then it becomes a question of what
the journalists are going to decide and
there are no rules on this although
there is some evidence based upon what
has happened in former crises in earlier
crises and I would say at this
particular point that journalists are
predisposed not to embarrass the
government if something comes up that is
embarrassing a wonderful reporter Jack
Kelly working for USA Today did a piece
last Friday in which he said that US
elite forces have been operating inside
Afghanistan for two weeks now and he ran
into a buzz
saw of jeering ugly criticism but it
turned around when first the white house
and then the Pentagon put out the word
very quietly that's right
it's okay and so then CNN went with it
at five o'clock that afternoon and then
a lot of newspapers went with it the
following day so they went to CNN they
went to the AP that sort of ratified
would USA Today had published and it was
okay but what was in the editors mind I
don't know for a fact but I can guess
you had to be extra careful that that
information was right balantine with the
terrorism war what we would call is not
for me well taken I think the press is
Denison Park job right here give you
what and said no but you you're talking
about the pitfalls and they're there
they're plenty of precedents all the
question of handling secret information
how you do it how you not doing
something and they're going to be
mistakes and there were stories that
were wrong in this crisis initially guys
arrested who were interested in
back-and-forth he this is the father boy
they're going to be mistakes but in
general I'm really amazed that the
mainstream press has done the job that
they have done oh not only excellent
coverage is Washington but extensive you
know from Moscow from
everywhere and I think it's something
that the American press so far I say
emphasize so far could be very proud
done I agree with you completely I share
your judgment I think the press up to
this point has been terrific but I think
Deborah Mathis is point that we are all
dependent on fewer and fewer sources of
information is still valid in terms of
understanding what the US government is
going to be doing at this particular
point there are fewer people qualified
to speak to you on not even on the
record but qualified to speak to you
about what it is that the US government
they do then for example existed during
the Gulf War the Vietnam War so that the
overall job has been I think at this
point outstanding I agree with that
completely
absolutely Mike Friedman Marvin were
obviously all absorbed and and engrossed
with with what's happening now in this
national tragedy but there's a story
that sandwiched in between what you've
written about and what we're dealing
with now how would you compare the
coverage of Lewinsky and President
Clinton to the coverage of congressman
Gary Condit and and the missing young
woman Chandra Levy were some lessons
learned and and how would you take CBS's
Lone Star decision to only run the story
once unfortunately given the choice
between Monica as Chandra Levy Gary
Condit story the press performance would
suggest that very little was learned in
the time between the two very little
indeed and I think what is happening now
and why reporters are thinking twice
three four times before they would go
with something and do go with something
is that everybody understands this is
not fun and games this is this is life
and death this is war and peace
and so there's another level of
seriousness and intense concentration
that goes into the reporting of anything
relating to this terrorist episodes
Walter right you start answering the
question I'm about to ask oh if you
compare Monica Lewinsky and the event of
three weeks weeks ago
you're comparing bottles with papas you
comparing comparing something that at
some level certainly by comparison is
very unserious until you escalated into
the president's lying with some with war
with life and death with war with people
dying but the purpose of the comparison
has to do with process and we have a
Content issue in which the contents of
the tube the two matters are very
different one is very grave one is one
is something else
just as scandal and a personal scandal
that became a national scam and the
other is process which is the press the
press as it works and I wonder how the
nature of the content affects the nature
of the process one scandalous story the
book is about the process of journalism
as practiced here in Washington during a
time of crisis and you are a very good
professor in a very good teacher because
that is exactly the split that you would
have to make between content and process
and I was trying to research the process
with a view toward trying to isolate
those elements in the performance of
journalism that can be taken from the
coverage of one major incident and apply
to the coverage of another that's what I
was trying to do when I I hope that in
the book I succeeded that was my very
much my attempt I think that's Bob Toth
in the back
and I think I'm going to take club and
mini one little question whether or not
you might see some parallel and
Watergate and Winston how many sources
did what was Bernstein have initially
yeah then I mean is wonderful the answer
is I don't know I don't know how many
sources they had they spoke vividly of
deep throat suggesting there was one key
source but it could be that that has
always been a cover for a number of
important sources there was only one
source initially run that was Monica
Road there was only one source initially
in water day Brazil and and my feeling
is that that what we see and the winds
give there really had its origins and
that the bob that could very well be
that that would happen during the
Lewinsky scandal had its origins in
Watergate and in a sense it did in terms
of the manner in which the press
observed the presidency you know it with
Watergate the presidency began to come
down from the clouds it had begun to
happen even before but with Watergate
rather dramatically it came down to the
point where the President had to
proclaim at one point I am NOT a crook
which was not the kind of thing that
Eisenhower or Roseville would have said
Bernard you already had your question
you already had your question
Judy Leno's you already had your
question Judy Meadows gets the last
question why when Clinton came to office
the media really never had a good
relationship I mean we pilot for Kennedy
as it is apparently Johnson all of these
people had all kinds of things in there
in their administration why was it that
the media really always are attacked
Clinton I could give a long and
complicated answer but I don't think
that anyone here wants to hear that
a Clinton to a certain extent not all
the way but to a certain extent asked
for it Clinton was the sort of person
who so wanted to be one of the boys that
he sort of felt it perfectly alright to
discuss on television what kind of
underwear he wore that so lacked dignity
that an awful lot of reporters could
then go on to feel that perhaps the
guy's talking about his underwear and
what he whereas he talked about any
number of other things and Clinton
wanted to do that he's a talker
the man is an unbelievable talker and a
very successful politician to turns as
president United States so I think that
the Clinton himself is such an
extraordinary figure that I believe that
$12,000,000 advance is actually going to
be eaten up in book sales because people
are going to want to know what is it
that he really really believes about his
wife about his daughter
about Monica and about all of the others
and about power and the relationship
really I get back to this one point the
first question I asked that the students
asked me how much privacy is a public
official entitled to have does he have a
right to a zone of privacy it's hard to
answer that question and but all of us
are absorbed with it without any doubt I
thank you all very much for coming I
appreciate that a lot